let's focus in now on lies while under
oath by Brett Kavanaugh we already
talked about how he straight-up didn't
answer many questions during that
hearing where we heard from Brett
Kavanaugh and from his first of many
accusers Christine Blasi Ford we already
talked about the fact that many times
senators started picking apart his
claims that he never blacked out from
drinking to the point where he might not
remember what he did on some nights we
already talked about how his sort of
baseline unhinged nature makes him
fundamentally unfit to be on the Supreme
Court but now I want to focus in on lies
that he told remember senators Jeff
Flake and Chris Coons who called for
this investigation last night said if
any lying is uncovered that's likely the
end of this nomination for Brett
Kavanaugh so this matters okay it's
really important to understand that
Cavanaugh is lying about lots of little
things and that should disqualify him
from being on the court even if it's
each individual lies small or relatively
unimportant it's still against the law
to lie under oath and it still makes him
a liar
people who know Cavanaugh are flooding
out saying he lied he lied many times
during the hearing every few hours
there's a new article with people who
know him saying this was a lie that was
a lie
Cavanaugh lied so much actually that
it's hard to even know where to start
but let's first start with his claim
about getting into Yale part of Brett
Kavanaugh is unhinged ranting on
Thursday included him saying that he got
into Yale on the basis of his hard work
and that he had no connections to Yale
whatsoever he his exact words that day
were a quote senator you were asking
about college I got into Yale Law School
that's the number one law school in the
country
I had no connections there I got there
by busting my tail in college this is a
lie Brett Kavanaugh was a legacy
admission to Yale meaning he had prior
family members who went to Yale his
grandfather
Everett Edward Cavanaugh went to Yale to
little lie it's one of many but why is
he lying all the time and why do we need
to excuse those lies he claimed that a
Devil's Triangle is a drinking game
it's
not other than references added from a
congressional IP address to Wikipedia
after his hearing he knows that it's a
sex act involving two men and a woman
and it's yet another lie he claimed that
the term boof related to flatulence
which it doesn't Cavanaugh knows that it
relates to anal sexual practices he
implied when talking about his drinking
that he was of legal age by saying you
know in 1982 I drank beer 18-year olds
could drink so the seniors could drink
legally that's right the seniors who
were 18 could drink legally he wasn't 18
at the time it's a small lie but it's
yet another lie and then there's kind of
like the bigger narrative lies okay
Cavanaugh's broader story was I just
didn't drink enough to forget stuff I
didn't drink enough to have foggy
memories despite the fact that senators
Booker and Blumenthal and others made a
Klobuchar and others made some pretty
significant progress in showing that
that wasn't true but before and since
Cavanaugh's testimony a bunch of his
classmates have come forward to say he
was frequently stumbling around drunk he
had no rational control over his actions
nor a clear recollection of them he was
asked during the hearing whether he
watched Christine Blasi Ford's testimony
he said no but I plan to watch it later
it was widely reported in multiple media
outlets that he was watching the
testimony the fact that Cavanaugh lied
so much about so many little things is
actually indicative of his they can't
touch me attitude which he shares with
who he shares that attitude with Donald
Trump when you were this willing to
perjure yourself you should not be on
the Supreme Court you really shouldn't
have any government job private
companies are free to decide Pat do they
care about the fact that this guy lies
all the time or not he really shouldn't
have any government job and as I said
before it's not likely that there's
going to be a perjury charge proven here
it's unlikely we're even going to get a
perjury charge but at least one senator
is getting tough on the crime of perjury
by Supreme Court nominees and that's
Bernie Sanders who has now actually
written a letter to Chuck Grassley
who's been running this entire circus of
a confirmation hearing saying the f
I should investigate not only the claims
of the accusers but also whether the guy
lied whether he perjured himself and in
his letter Bernie Sanders said in order
for this FBI investigation regarding
Judge Brett Cavanaugh's nomination to be
complete it is imperative the bureau
must not only look into the accusations
made by dr. Ford Deborah Ramirez and
Julie sweat NIC which they're not doing
by the way it should also examine the
veracity of his testimony before the
Judiciary Committee obviously Bernie
also points out that they should
investigate the claims of all three
women they're not doing that either
Julie sweat Nick attempting to get in
touch with no luck I would make the case
actually that perjury allegations or
maybe more damaging than the sexual
assault allegations not that lying about
what booth means is worse than raping a
woman that's not what I mean but what I
mean is no matter what the FBI comes up
with with regard to sexual assault it's
still gonna be a preponderance of
evidence thing and more than half of
Republicans as I'll tell you later don't
even think sex assault should disqualify
you from the Supreme Court in that sense
if you perjure yourself it's much more
cut and dry Republicans will still say I
don't care put him on the court but I
actually think that you you can make the
case that being a sloppy drunk in
college isn't necessarily disqualifying
from being on the Supreme Court lying
about it constantly as an adult under
oath however should disqualify you from
being on the court it's all just so hard
to prove though like when he claims that
Boo f---ing related to flatulence not
anal sex or The Devil's Triangle that's
a drinking game not a sex act I mean in
his circles he could claim that that's
what those terms meant you can't just
cite urban dictionary and say there's
the discrepancy here or you know I mean
his classmates will come out and say
that this guy drank a lot in college
right he was intoxicated every Friday
and Saturday night and it's it's
unbelievable to think that he could
remember some of that stuff well hey if
he says that he didn't black out how are
you gonna prove otherwise and when it
comes to perjury it does involve whether
he was deliberately saying something
that wasn't true or whether he genuinely
is just mistaken so it's an uphill
battle but I agree with Bernie that the
lying has got to be investigated here
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the
Joe is on twitter at david pakman show
we've got a great program for you today
one of today's sponsors is Skillshare
which is an amazing online learning
community that offers thousands of high
quality classes on almost any topic
first 500 people who click the link
under this video will get two entire
months of totally free access to every
single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything from
design video editing photography
business technology cooking meditation
even classes on personal productivity I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or even
something that will help you in your
everyday life classes are taught by real
people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of skill share but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up